Center carullius is a part of a group  called The cilius as is true of all  ciliates stencorelius have hair-like  structures called cilia the beating of  the Cilia propels these cells in the  water when they want to move around and  it also brings food particles micro  animals and single-celled organisms into  the cell mouth where they are taken  inside the cell to be digested just like  this multicellular rotifer which is  swallowed by the Giant stentor caruleus  and waiting to be digested after 25  minutes the rotifer ceased its struggle  stentacruelius can be cannibalistic as  well however no one has ever managed to  record the initial swallowing this is  likely because the light of the  microscope disturbs the cells here we  see a stenter making a go of that but  luckily for the little one it's a bit  too big of a bite